hi everybody I'm a bread skill I'm an
assistant professor in computer science
and welcome to CS 234 which is a
reinforcement learning class which is
designed to be sort of an entry level
masters or PhD student in an
introduction to reinforcement learning
so what we're gonna do today is I'm
gonna start with just sort of a really
short brief overview of what is
reinforcement learning and then we're
gonna go through course logistics and
when I go through course logistics
I'll also pause and ask for any
questions about logistics the website is
now live and so that's also the best
source of information about the class
that in Piazza will be the best source
of information so I'll stop there will
be get to that part to ask if there's
any things I don't go over that you have
questions about and if you have
questions about the wait list or any
particular things relating to your own
circumstance feel free to come up to me
at the end and then the third part of
the class is going to be where we start
to get into the technical content of
we're thinking about an introduction to
sequential decision making under
uncertainty
just so I have a sense before we get
started who here has taken a machine
learning class all right who cares
taking AI okay so a little bit less but
most people alright great so probably
everybody here has seen a little bit
about reinforcement learning varies a
little bit depending on where you've
been at we will be covering stuff
starting from the beginning as if you
don't know any reinforcement learning
but then we're rapidly beginning to
other content that's beyond anything
that's covered in at least other
Stanford related classes so Ranbir's
what learning is concerned with this
really foundational issue of how can
intelligent agent learn to make a good
sequence of decisions and that's sort of
a single sentence that summarizes what
reinforcement learning is doing and what
will recovery during this class but it
actually encodes a lot of really
important ideas so the first thing is
that we're really concerned now with
sequences of decisions so in contrast to
a lot of what is covered in machine
learning we're gonna be thinking about
agents intelligent agents or an
intelligent agent in general that might
or might not be human or biological and
how it could make not just one decision
but a whole sequence of decisions
we're gonna be concerned with goodness
in other words we're gonna be interested
the second thing is how do we learn to
make good decisions and what we mean by
good here is some notion of optimality
we have some utility measure over the
decisions that are being made and the
final critical aspect of reinforcement
learning is the learning but that the
agent doesn't know in advance how its
decisions are going to affect the world
or what decisions might necessarily be
associated with good outcomes and
instead it has to acquire that
information through experience so when
we think about this this is really
something that we do all the time we've
done it since we were babies we try to
figure out how would you sort of achieve
high reward in the world and there's a
lot of really exciting work that's going
on in neuroscience and psychology that's
trying to think about the same
fundamental issue from the perspective
of human intelligent agents and so I
think that if we want to be able to
solve AI or make significant progress we
have to be able to make significant
progress in allowing us to create agents
that do reinforcement learning so where
does this come up there's this nice
example from Yale min who's an amazing
school psychologist a neuroscience
research over at Princeton where she
gives us an example of this sort of
primitive creature which evolves as
following during its lifetime so when
it's a baby it has a primitive brain and
one eye and it swims around and it
attaches to a rock and then what is an
adult it digests its brain and it sits
there and so maybe this is some
indication that the point of
intelligence or the point of having a
brain and at least in part is helping to
guide decisions and so that once all the
decisions in the agent's life has been
completed
maybe we no longer need a brain so I
think this is you know this is one
example of a biological creature but I
think it's a useful reminder to think
about why would an agent need to be
intelligent and is it somehow
fundamentally related to the fact that
it has to make decisions now of course
there's been a sort of really a paradigm
shift in reinforcement learning around
in the Nerds conference which is one of
the main machine learning conferences
David Silva came and went to a workshop
and presented these incredible results
of using reinforcement learning to
directly control Atari games now these
are important and whether you like video
games or not video games are a really
interesting example of sort of complex
tasks that take human players a while
often to learn we don't know how to do
them in advance it takes us at least a
little bit of experience and what the
really incredible thing about this
example was this is a breakout is that
the agent learns to play directly from
pixel input so from the agents
perspective they're just seeing sort of
these colored pixels coming in and it's
having to learn what's the right
decisions to make in order to learn to
play the game well and in fact even
better than people so this was really
incredible that this was possible when I
first heard of doing reinforcement
learning a lot of their work was really
focused on very artificial toy problems
a lot of the foundations were there but
these sort of larger scale applications
were really lacking and so I think in
the last five years we've seen really a
huge improvement in the types of
techniques that are going on in
reinforcement learning and in the scale
of the problems that can be tackled now
it's not just in video game playing it's
also in things like robotics and
particularly some of my colleagues up at
University of california-berkeley have
been doing some really incredible work
on robotics and using reinforcement
learning in these types of scenarios to
try to have agents do grasping fold
clothes things like that
now those sort of examples if you guys
have looked reinforcement learning
before are probably the ones you've
heard about you've probably heard about
things like video games or robotics but
one of the things that I think is really
exciting is that reinforcement learning
is actually applicable to a huge number
of domains which is both an opportunity
and a responsibility so in particular I
direct the AI for human impact lab here
at Stanford and one of the things that
we're really interested in is how do we
use artificial intelligence to help
amplify human potential so one way you
can imagine doing that is through
something like educational games where
the goal is to figure out how to quickly
and effectively
teach people how to learn material such
as fractions another really important
application areas healthcare this is
sort of a cutout of looking at seizures
that some work that's been done by
Joelle Pineau up at McGill University
and I think there's also a lot of cute
excitement right now of thinking about
how can we use AI and in particular
reinforcement learning to do things like
to interact with things like electronic
medical record systems and use them to
inform patient treatment there's also a
lot of recent excitement in thinking
about how we can use reinforcement
learning and lots of other applications
kind of as an optimization technique for
when it's really hard to solve
optimization problems and so this is
arising in things like natural language
processing and vision and a number of
other areas so I think if we have to
think about what are the key aspects of
reinforcement learning
they probably boil down to the following
four and these are things that are going
to distinguish it from other aspects of
AI and machine learning so reinforcement
learning from my sentence about that
we're learning to make good decisions
under uncertainty fundamentally involves
optimization delayed consequences
exploration and generalization so
optimization naturally comes up because
we're interested in good decisions
there's some notion of relative
different types of decisions that we can
make and we want to be able to get
decisions that are good the second
situation is delayed consequences so
this is the challenge that the decisions
that are made now you might not realize
whether or not they're a good decision
until much later so you eat the
chocolate sundae now and you don't
realize until an hour later that that
was a bad idea to eat all two quarts of
ice cream or you in the case of things
like video games like Montezuma's
Revenge you have to pick up a key and
then much later you realize that's
helpful or you study really hard now on
Friday night and then three weeks you do
well on the midterm so one of the
challenges to doing this is that because
you don't necessary sieve immediate
outcome feedback it can be hard to do
what is known as the credit assignment
problem which is how do you figure out
the causal relationship between the
decisions you made in the
and the outcomes in the future and
that's a really different problem than
we tend to see in most of machine
learning so one of the things that comes
up when we start to think about this is
how do we do exploration so the agent is
fundamentally trying to figure out how
the world works
through experience in much of
reinforcement learning and so we think
about the agent is really kind of being
this scientist of trying things out in
the world like having an agent that
tries to ride a bicycle and then
learning about how physics and writing
it a balance like Gert works by falling
now one of the really big challenges
here is that data is censored and what
we mean by censoring in this case is
that you only get to learn about what
you try to do so all of you guys are
here at Stanford clearly that was the
optimal choice but you don't actually
get to figure out what it would have
been like if you went to MIT it's
possible that would have been a good
choice as well but you can't you can't
experience that because you only get to
live once and so you only get to see the
particular choice you met it at this
particular time so one question you
might wonder about is you know policy
what we're gonna we're gonna talk a lot
about policies policies decision
policies is going to be some mapping
from experiences to a decision and you
might answer why you eat this needs to
be learned so if we think about
something like deep mind a tari playing
game what it was learning from here is
it was learning from pixels so it was
essentially learning from the space of
images what to do next and if you wanted
to write that down as a program a series
of if-then statements it would be
absolutely enormous this is not
tractable but this is why we need some
form of generalization why it may be
much better for us to learn from data
directly as well as to have some
high-level representation of the task so
that even if we then run into a
particular configuration of pixels we've
never seen before our agent can still
know what to do so these are the four
things that really make up reinforcement
learning at least online reinforcement
learning and why are they different than
some other types of AI and machine
learning so another thing that comes up
a lot in artificial intelligence is
planning
so for example the go game is can be
thought of as a planning problem so what
does planning involve evolves
optimization often generalization and
delayed consequences
you might take a move and go early and
it might not be immediately obvious if
that was a good move until many steps
later but it doesn't involve exploration
so the idea and planning is that you're
given a model of how the world works
you're given the rules of the game for
example and you know what the reward is
and the hard part is computing what you
should do given the model of the world
so it doesn't require exploration in
supervised machine learning versus
reinforcement learning it often involves
optimization and generalization but
frequently it doesn't involve either
exploration or delayed consequences so
it doesn't tend to involve exploration
because typically in supervised learning
you're given a data set so your agent
isn't collecting its experience or data
about the world instead it's given
experience and that it has to use that
to say and for whether an image is a
face or not similarly it's typically
making essentially one decision like
whether this image is a face or not
instead of having to think about making
decisions now and then only learning
whether or not those the right decisions
later unsupervised machine learning
aweful also involves optimization and
generalization but generally does not
involve exploration or delayed
consequences and typically you have no
labels for about the world so in
supervised learning you often get the
exact label for the world like this
image really is has it contains a face
or not in unsupervised learning you
normally get no labels about the world
and an RL you typically get something
kind of halfway in between those which
you get a a utility of the label you put
so for example you might decide that
there's a face in here and it might say
okay yeah we'll give you partial credit
for that because maybe there's something
that looks sort of like a face you don't
get the true label of the world or maybe
you decide to go to Stanford and then
you don't know and you're like okay that
was a really great experience but I
don't know if it was quote-unquote the
right experience imitation learning
which is something that
probably touched on briefly in this
class and is becoming very important
it's similar but a little bit different
so in it involves optimization
generalization and often delayed
consequences but the idea is that we're
going to be learning from experience
with others so instead of our
intelligent agent getting to experiences
from the world of make its own decisions
it might watch another intelligent agent
which might be a person make decisions
observe outcomes and then use that
experience to figure out how it wants to
act you'll be a lot of benefits to doing
this it's a little bit different because
it doesn't have to directly think about
the exploration problem imitation
learning I just want to spend a little
bit more time on that one because it's
been come increasingly important so to
my knowledge it was first really sort of
popularized by Andrew II Pam who's a
former professor here through some of
his helicopter stuff where he was
looking at expert flights together with
Peter Beale he's a professor over at
Berkeley to see how you could imitate
very quickly experts flying toy
helicopters that was one of sort of the
first kind of major application
successes of invitation learning it can
be very effective there can be some
challenges to it because essentially if
you get to observe one trajectory let's
imagine it's a circle of a helicopter
flying and your agent learn something
that isn't exactly the same as what the
expert was doing that you can
essentially start to go off that path
and rent venture into territory where
you really don't know what the right
thing is to do so there's been a lot of
extensive work on invitation learning
that sort of combining between imitation
learning and reinforcement learning that
ends up being very promising so in terms
of how we think about trying to do
reinforcement learning we can build on a
lot of these different types of
techniques and then also think about
some of the challenges that are unique
to reinforcement learning which involves
all four of these challenges and so
these RL agents really need to explore
the world and then use that exploration
to guide their future decisions so we'll
talk more about this throughout the
course a really important question that
comes up with we're do these rewards
come from where is this information
the agents are using to try to guide
whether or not their decisions are good
and who is providing those and what
happens if they're wrong and we'll talk
a lot more about that we won't talk very
much about multi-agent reinforcement
learning systems but that's also a
really important case as well as
thinking about game theoretic aspects
all right so that's just a bit of a
really short overview about some of the
aspects of reinforcement learning and
why it's different than some of the
other classes that you might have taken
and now we're gonna go briefly through
course logistics and then start through
more of the content and I'll pause after
course logistics to ask for any
questions in terms of prerequisites and
we expect that everybody here has either
taken an AI class or a machine learning
class either here at Stanford or the
equivalent and another institution if
you're not sure whether or not you have
the right background for the class feel
free to reach out to us on Piazza and
we'll respond if you've done extensive
work and sort of related stuff it'll
probably be sufficient in general we
expect that you have basic Python
proficiency and that you're familiar
with probability statistics and
multivariable calculus things like
gradient descent loss derivatives those
should all be very familiar to you and I
expect that most people have probably
heard of MVPs before but it's not
totally critical so this is the long
list so I'll go through it slowly
because I think it's pretty important so
this is what are the goals for the class
and what are the learning objectives so
these are the things that we expect that
you guys should be able to do by the
time you finish this class and that it's
our role to help you be able to
understand how to do these things and so
the first thing is that it's important
to be able to define the key features of
reinforcement learning that distinguish
it from other types of AI machine
learning frames of problems so that's
what I was doing a little bit of so far
in this class to figure out how does
this distinguish this how does our I'll
distinguish itself from other types of
problems so related to that for most of
you you will probably not end up being
academics and most of you will go into
industry and so one of the big
challenges when you do that is that when
you're faced with a particular problem
from your boss or when you're giving a
problem to one of your
supervisees is for them to think about
whether or not it should be framed as a
reinforcement learning problem and what
things are applicable to it so I think
it's very important but by the end of
this class that you have a sensitive if
you're given a real-world problem like
web advertising or patient treatment or
robotics problem that you have a sense
whether or not it is useful to formulate
it as a reinforcement learning problem
and how to write it down in that
framework and what algorithms are
relevant during that class will also be
introducing you to a number of
reinforcement learning algorithms and
you will have the chance to implement
those in code including deep
reinforcement learning problems another
really important aspect is if you're
trying to decide what tools to use for a
particular say robotics problem or
healthcare problem is to understand
which of the algorithms is likely to be
beneficial and why and so in addition to
things like empirical performance I
think it's really important to
understand generally how do we evaluate
algorithms and can we use things like
theoretical tools like regret sample
complexity as well as things like
computational complexity to decide which
algorithms are suitable for particular
tasks and then the final thing is that
one really important aspect of
reinforcement learning is exploration
versus exploitation this issue that
arises with an agent's have to figure
out what decisions they want to make and
what they're going to learn about the
environment by making those decisions
and so by the end of the class you
should also be able to compare different
types of techniques for doing
exploration versus exploitation and what
are the strengths and limitations of
these does that may have any questions
about what these learning objectives are
okay so we'll have three main
assignments for the class we'll also
have a midterm I will have a quiz at the
end of the class as well as a final
project the quiz is a little bit unusual
so I just want to spend a little bit of
time talking about it right now the quiz
is done on both individually and in
groups
the reason that we do this is because we
want a low-stakes way to sort of have
people practice with the material that
they learn in the second half of the
course in a way that sort of fun
engaging and really tries to get you to
think about it and also learn from your
peers and so we did it last year and I
think a number of people were a little
bit nervous about how it would go before
and then ended up really enjoying it so
the way that the quiz works is it's a
multiple-choice quiz at the beginning
everybody does it by themselves and then
after everybody has submitted their
answers then we do it again in groups
that are pre assigned by us and the goal
is that you have to get everyone to
decide on what the right answer is
before you scratch off and see what the
correct answer is
and then we graded according to what you
scratched off the right answer correctly
first or not you can't do worse than
your individual grade so join in a group
can only help you
and for SCPD students they don't do it
in groups so they just write down
justifications for their answers again
it's a pretty lightweight way to do
assessment the goal is that you sort of
have to be able to articulate why you
believe that answers are the way they
are and discuss them in small groups and
they use that information and use that
to figure out what the correct answer is
the final project is probably pretty
similar to other projects that you guys
have done in other classes it's an
open-ended project it's a chance to
reason about and think about
reinforcement learning stuff in more
depth we will also be offering a default
project that will be announced over the
next couple weeks before the first
milestone is due if you choose to do the
default project your break down because
you will not need to do a proposal or
milestone will be based on the project
presentation in your assignment right
now since we believe that you guys are
all of each other's best resource we use
Piazza and that should be used for
pretty much all class communication
unless it's something of sort of a
private or sensitive matter in which
case of course please feel free to reach
out to the course staff directly and for
things like lectures and homeworks and
project questions
my Drollet that should go through Piazza
for late-day policy we have six late
days for details you can see the web
page and for collaboration please see
the web page for some of the details
about that so before we go on to the
next part so they might have any
questions about logistics for the class
okay let's get started and so we're now
gonna do an introduction to sequential
decision making under uncertainty a
number of you guys will have seen some
of this content before we will be going
into this in pray more depth than you've
seen for some of this stuff including
some theory not theory today but in
other lectures and then we'll also be
moving on to content that will be new to
all of you later in the class so
sequential decision making under
uncertainty the fundamental that we
think thing that we think about in these
settings is sort of an interactive
closed-loop process where we have some
agent and intelligent agent hopefully
that it's taking actions that are
affecting the state of the world and
then it's giving back an observation and
a reward the key goal is that the agent
is trying to maximize the total expected
future reward now this expected aspect
is going to be important because
sometimes the world itself will be
stochastic and so the agent is going to
be maximizing things an expectation this
may not always be the right criteria
this has been what has been focused on
for the majority of reinforcement
learning but there's now some interest
in thinking about distribution of all RL
and some other aspects one of the key
challenges here is that it can require
balancing between immediate and
long-term rewards and that it might
require strategic behavior in order to
achieve those high rewards indicating
that you might have to sacrifice initial
higher rewards in order to achieve
longer better rewards over the long term
so as an example something like web
advertising might be that you have a
agent that is running the website and it
has to choose which web ad to give to a
customer the customer gives you back an
observation such as how long they spent
on the webpage and also you get some
information about whether
they click on an ad and the goal is to
say have people click on ads the most so
you have to pick which ad to show people
so that they're gonna click on ads
another example is a robot that's
unloading a dishwasher so in this case
the action space of the agent might be
joint movements and the information the
agent might get back was a camera image
of the kitchen and it might get a +1
reward if there are no dishes on the
counter so in this case it would
generally be a delayed reward for a long
time they're going to be dishes on the
counter unless it can just sweep all of
them off and have them crash onto the
floor which may or may not be the
intended goal of the person who's
writing this system and so it may have
to make a sequence of the decisions
where it can't get any reward for a long
time
another example is something like blood
pressure control where the actions might
be things like prescribe exercise or
prescribed medication and we get an
observation back of what is the blood
pressure of the individual and then the
reward might be +1 if it's in that if
the blood pressure is in a healthy range
maybe a small negative reward if
medication is prescribed due to side
effects it may be their reward otherwise
okay so let's think about another case
like some of the cases that I think
about in my lab like having an
artificial tutor so now what you could
have is you could have a teaching agent
and what it gets to do is pick an
activity so pick a teaching activity now
let's say it only has two different
types of teaching activities to get it's
going to either give an addition
activity or subtraction activity and it
gives this to a student and then the
student either gets the problem right
right or wrong and let's say the student
it initially does not know addition or
subtraction so it's a kindergartner the
student doesn't know anything about math
and we're trying to figure out how to
teach the student math and that the
reward structure for the teaching agent
is they get a plus one every time the
student gets something right and they
get a minus one if the student gets it
wrong so
I'd like you just take a minute turn to
somebody nearby and describe what you
think an agent that's trying to learn to
maximize its expected rewards would do
in this type of case what type of
problems it would give to the student
and whether or not that is doing the
right thing
[Music]
and let me just
and let me just clarify here and let me
just clarify here let me just clarify
here but let's assume that for most
students addition is easier than
subtraction so that like what it says
here that the problem even though the
student doesn't know either these things
that the skill of learning addition is
simpler for a new student to learn than
subtraction so what would what might
happen under those cases so then maybe
we want to raise their hand and tell me
what they and somebody nearby them was
thinking might happen for an agent in
this scenario the agent would give them
really easy addition problems that's
correct and that's exactly actually what
happened that there's a nice paper from
approximately 2000 with Bev Wolfe which
is one of the earliest ones that I know
were there using reinforcement learning
to create an intelligent tutoring system
and the reward was for the agent to give
problems to the student in order to get
them correct because you know if the
students giving things correct them
they've learned them but the problem
here is with that reward specification
what the agent learns to do is to give
really easy problems and then maybe the
student doesn't know how to do those
initially but then they quickly learn
how and then there's no incentive to
give card problems so this is just sort
of a small example of what is known as
reward hacking which is that your agent
is gonna learn to do exactly what it is
that you tell them to do in terms of the
rewards function that you specify and
yet in reinforcement learning often we
spend very little of our time thinking
very carefully about what that reward
function is so whenever you get out into
sort of the real world this is the
really really critical part but normally
it is the designer that gets to pick
what the reward function is the agent is
not having an intrinsic internal reward
and so depending on how you specify it
the agent will learn to do different
things yeah with no question the back ah
this in this case it seems like the
student would also be an RL agent and
that I can real like the student who
does profess but like we asked for
harder questions in different words
nonsense so if something like tech needs
to approach that or is it okay to be
so the question was to say well you know
we also think that people are probably
reinforcement learning agents as well
and that's exactly correct and maybe
they would start to say hey I need to
get harder questions or be interactive
in this process for most of this class
we're going to ignore the fact that the
world that we react with itself might
also be an RL agent in reality it's
really critical sometimes this is often
considered in an adversarial way like
for game theory I think one of the most
exciting things to me is when we think
about it in a cooperative way so who
here has heard about the sub-discipline
of machine teaching nobody yet and so
it's a really interesting new area
that's been around for maybe five to ten
years a little bit beyond that and one
of the ideas there is what happens if
you have two intelligent agents that are
interacting with each other where they
know that each other's trying to help
them so there's a really nice classic
example from sorry for those of you that
aren't so familiar with machine learning
but imagine that you're trying to learn
a classifier to decide we're along this
line things are either positive or
negative so in general you're going to
need some amount of samples samples if
you wear that sort of the number of
points on the line where you have to get
positive or negative labels if you're in
an active learning setting generally I
think you can reduce that to roughly log
N by being strategic about asking people
to label particularly points in the line
one of the really cool things for
machine teaching is that if I know you
are trying to teach me where to divide
this line you only need one point all
right most two points essentially
constant right because if I'm trying to
teach you there's no way I'm just gonna
randomly label things I'm just gonna
label you a single plus and a minus and
that's gonna tell you exactly where the
line goes so that's one of the reasons
why if the agent knows that the other
agent is trying to teach them something
it can actually be enormous ly more
efficient than what we normally think of
for learning and so I think there's a
lot of potential for machine teaching to
be really effective but all that said
we're gonna ignore most of that for the
course and if it's something you want to
explore in your project you're very
welcome to there's a lot of connections
with reinforcement learning
okay so if we think about this process
in general if we think of service
sequential decision-making process we
have this agent we're gonna think about
almost always about there being discrete
timer so agents gonna make a decision
it's gonna affect the world in some way
it's gonna see it the world is going to
give some new observation and a reward
and the agent receives those and uses it
to make another decision so in this case
when we think about a history what we
mean by history is simply the sequence
of previous actions that the agent took
and the observations and rewards that
received and then the second thing
that's really important is to define a
state space again often when this is
first discussed this is sort of thought
about as some immutable thing but
whenever you're in a real application
this is exactly what you have to define
is how to write down the representation
of the world what we're going to assume
in this class is that this data is a
function of the history so there might
be other aspects of there might be other
sensory information that the agent would
like to have access to in order to make
its decision but it's gonna be
constrained to the observations that's
received so far the actions it's taken
and the rewards that's observed now
there's also going to be some real-world
state so that's the real world and the
agent doesn't necessarily have access to
the real world they may have access only
to a small subset of the real world so
for example as a human right now I have
eyes that allow me to look forward you
know roughly 180 degrees but I can't see
behind my head but behind my head is
still part of the world state so the
world state is the real world and then
the agent has its own state space it
uses to try to make decisions so in
general we're going to assume that some
function of the history now one
assumption that we're going to use a lot
in this class which you guys have
probably seen before is the Markov
assumption and the Markov assumption
simply says that we're going to assume
that the state used by the agent is a
sufficient statistic of the history in
the in order to predict the future you
only need to know the current state of
the environment so this simply basically
indicates that the future is independent
of the past given the present if in the
present you have the right a grits t't
istic
so as a couple examples of this ya
question Damon so the state if we think
about something like a robot um so let's
say you have a robot that is walking
down a long corridor let's say there's
two long corridors okay so your robot
starts here this is where your robot
starts and it tries to go right right
and then it goes down down down and
let's say it sensors are just that it
can observe whether in front of it I
whether there is a wall on any of its
sides so it can the observation space at
the robot is simply is there a wall on
any side on each it's four sides I'm
sorry that's very little bit small in
the back the agent basically has you
know some sort of local amount laser
rangefinders something like that so it
knows whether or not there's a wall
immediately around it
let's rip an immediate round it Square
and nothing else so in this case what
the agent would see is that initially
the wall looks like this and then like
this like this and the history would
include all of this but it's local state
is just this so the local state could
just be the current observation and that
starts to be important when you're going
down here because there are many places
that look like that and so if you keep
track of the whole history the agent can
figure out where it is but if it only
keeps track of where it is locally then
a lot of partial aliasing can occur so I
put up a couple examples here so it's
something like hypertension control you
could imagine the state is just the
current blood pressure when your action
is whether to take medication or not so
car blow push your meeting like you know
every second for example what is your
blood pressure so do you think this sort
of system is Markov I see some people
shaking their heads
almost
probably not almost definitely there are
other features that have to do with you
know maybe whether or not you're
exercising whether or not you just ate a
meal whether it's hot outside what if
you just got in an airplane all these
other features probably affect whether
or not your next blood pressure is going
to be higher low and particularly in
response to some medication
similarly in something like website
shopping can imagine the state is just
sort of what is the product you're
looking at right now
so like I open on Amazon I'm looking at
some you know computer and that's up on
my webpage right now and the action is
what other products to recommend do you
think that system is Markov systems not
Markov you mean the system generally but
that the assumption is Marko question is
whether or not the system generally is
Markov and the assumption just doesn't
fit or just some more details I think
about this what I mean here is that this
particular choice of representing the
system is that Markov and so there's the
real world going on and then there's
sort of the model of the world that the
agent can use and what I'm arguing here
is that these particular models of the
world are not Markov there might be
other models of the world that are but
if we choose this particular observation
say just the current blood pressure is
our state that is probably not really a
Markov state now it doesn't mean that we
can't use algorithms that treat it as if
it is it's just that we should be aware
that we might be violating some of those
assumptions yeah so if you included ever
enough history into a state can you make
any problem at all that's a great
question so why is it so popular chin
you know can you always make something
Markov generally yes if you include all
the history then you can always make the
system Markov in practice often you can
get away with just using the most recent
observation or maybe the last four
observations as a reasonably sufficient
statistic it depends a lot on the domain
there is certainly domain may be like
the navigation world I put up there
where it's really important to model
either use the whole history as the as
the state or think about the partial
observability and other cases where you
know maybe the current this most recent
observation
completely sufficient now one of the
challenges here is you might not want to
use the whole history because that's a
lot of information and you have to keep
track of it over time and so it's much
nicer to have sort of a sufficient
statistic of course some of these things
are changing a little bit with LST M's
and other things like that so some of
our prior assumptions about sort of how
things scale with the size of the state
space so changing a little bit right now
with deep learning but historically
certainly there's been advantages to
having a smaller state space and again
historically there's been a lot of
implications for things like
computational complexity the data
required and the resulting performance
depending on the size of the state space
so just to give some intuition for why
that might be if you made your state
everything that's ever happened to in
your life that would give you a really
really rich representation but you would
only have one data point for every state
there would be no repeating so it's
really hard to learn because they're all
States are different and in general if
we want to learn how to do something
we're going to either need some form of
generalization or some form of
clustering or aggregation so that we can
compare experiences so that we can learn
from prior similar experience in order
to what to do so if we think about
assuming that your observation is your
state so the most recent observation
that the agent gets we're gonna treat
that as the state then we the agent is
modeling the world as a Markov decision
process so it is thinking of taking an
action getting an observation in reward
and it's setting the state the world
state that it's the environment state
it's using to be the observation if the
world if it is treating the world is
partially observable then it says the
agent state is not the same and it sort
of uses things like the history or
beliefs about the world state to
aggregate the sequence of previous
actions taken and the observations
received and uses that to make its
decisions for example and something like
poker you get to see your own cards
other people have cards that are clearly
affecting the course of the game but you
don't necessary know what those are
there you can see which cards are
discarded
and so that's somewhere where it's
naturally partially observable and so
you can maintain a belief state over
what the other cards are at the other
players you can use that information or
to make your decisions and similarly
often in health care there's a whole
bunch of really complicated
physiological processes that are going
on but you could monitor parts of them
for things like you know blood pressure
or temperature etc and then use that in
order to make decisions so in terms of
types of sequential decision making
processes one of them is Bandits
we'll talk more about this later the
term Bandits is sort of a really simple
version of a Markov decision process in
this sense that the idea is that the
actions that are taken have no influence
over the next observation so when might
this be reasonable so let's imagine that
you have a series of customers coming to
your website you show each of them an ad
so and then they either click on it or
not and then you get another customer
login and Cheer website so in this case
the ad that you show to customer one
generally doesn't affect who cuz which
customer to comes along now it could
maybe even really complicated ways maybe
customer one goes to Facebook and says I
really really love this ad you should go
watch it but most the time
whatever ad you showed a customer one
does not at all affect who next logs
into your website and so the decisions
you make only affect the local the the
first customer and then the customer to
is totally independent bandits have been
really really important for at least 50
years people thought about them for
things like clinical trials how to
allocate people to clinical trials
people think of them for websites and a
whole bunch of other applications
MVP's and pom DPS say no wait the
actions that you take can affect the
state of the world they affect often the
next observation you get as well as the
reward and you have to think about this
closed loop system the actions that
you're taking changing the state of the
world so the product that I recommend my
customer might affect what the customers
opinion is on the next time step in fact
you hope it will and so in these cases
we think about the actions actually
affecting the state of the world so
another really important question is how
the world changes one idea is that it
just deterministically so when you take
an action in a particular state you go
to a different state but that the state
you go to is deterministic there's only
one
this is often a pretty common assumption
a lot of robotics and controls I
remember and Tomas was on a press who's
a professor at MIT once are you
suggesting to me that if you flip a coin
it's actually a deterministic process we
just model it's stochastic we don't have
good enough models so there are many
processes that if you could sort of
write down a sufficient perfect model of
the world it would actually look to
terminus take but in many cases even it
may be hard to write down those models
and so we're gonna approximate them as
stochastic and the idea is that then
when we take an action there are many a
possible outcomes so you couldn't show
an ad to someone and they may or may not
click on it and we may just want to
represent that with a stochastic
stochastic model so let's think about a
particular example so if we think about
something like Mars rover I when we
deploy Rovers or robots on really far
off planets it's hard to do
communication back and forth so it'd be
nice to be able to make these sort of
robots more autonomous
let's imagine that we have a very simple
Mars rover that's thinking about a seven
state system so it's just landed it's
got a particular location and it can
either try to go left or try to go there
right I write down try left or try right
meaning that that's what it's gonna try
to do but maybe you'll succeed or fail
let's imagine that there's different
sorts of scientific information to be
discovered and so over an s1 there is a
little bit of useful scientific
information but actually over an s7
there's an incredibly rich place where
there might be water and then there's
zero in all other states so we'll go
through that is a little bit of an
example as I start to talk about
different common components of an RL
agent so one often common component is a
model so a model is simply going to be a
representation the agent has for what
happens in the world is it takes its
actions and what rewards that might get
so in the case of a Markov decision
process it's simply a model that says if
I start in this state and I take this
action a what is the distribution over
next States I might reach
and it also is gonna have a reward model
that predicts the expected reward of
taking an action in a certain state so
in this case let's imagine that the
reward of the agent is that it thinks
that there's zero reward everywhere and
let's imagine that it thinks it's motor
control is very bad and so it estimates
that whenever it tries to move with 50
percent probability it stays in the same
place and 50 percent probability it
actually moves now the model can be
wrong so if you remember what I put up
here the actual reward is that in state
s1 you get plus 1 and in state s7 you
get s so you get 10 and everything else
you get 0 and the reward I just wrote
down here is that it's 0 everywhere so
this is a totally reasonable reward
model the agent could have it just
happens to be wrong and in many cases
the model will be wrong but often can
still be used by the agent in useful
ways so the next important component
that is always needed by an RL agent is
a policy and the policy or decision
policy is simply how we make decisions
now because we're thinking about Markov
decision processes here we're going to
think about them as being mappings from
States to actions and the deterministic
policy simply means there's one action
per state and the stochastic means you
can have a distribution over actions you
might take so maybe every time you drive
to the airport you flip a coin you
decide whether you're gonna take the
back roads or whether you're gonna take
the highway so as a quick check imagine
that in every single state we do the
action try right is this the
deterministic policy or stochastic
policy deterministic kibriya
we'll talk more about why deterministic
policies are useful and when stochastic
policies are useful shortly now the
value function is the expected
discounted sum of future rewards under a
particular policy so it's a weighting
it's saying how much reward do I think
I'm gonna get both now and in the future
weighted by how much I care about
immediate versus long-term rewards the
discount factor gamma is gonna be
between 0 and 1
and so the value function then allows us
to say sort of how good or bad different
states are so again in the case of the
Mars rover let's imagine that our
discount factor is zero our policy is to
try to go right and in this case say
this is our value function it says that
the value of being in state 1 is +1
everything else is 0 and the value of
being in s 7 is 10 again this minor
might not be the correct value function
depends also on the true dynamics model
but this is a value function that the
agent could have for this policy simply
tells us what is the expected discounted
sum of rewards you'd get if you follow
this policy starting in the state we
weigh each reward by gamma 2 the number
of time steps at which you reach it so
when we think about yeah so if we wanted
to extend this kind of a factor to this
example there be like an increasing
value or decreasing value to the reward
yes
question was if the gamma was not zero
here so gamma is being zero here
indicates that essentially we just care
about immediate rewards whether or not
we'd start to assert it avange to
correctly start to see like rewards flew
into other states and the answer is yes
so we'll see more of that next time but
if the discount factor is nonzero then
it basically says you care about not
just the immediate reward you get you're
not just myopic you care about the
reward you're gonna get in the future so
in terms of common types of
reinforcement learning agents some of
them are model-based which means they
maintain in their representation a
direct model of how the world works like
a transition model and a reward model
and they may or may not have a policy or
value function they always have to
compute a policy they have to figure out
what to do but they may or may not have
an explicit representation for what they
would do in any state model free
approaches have an explicit value
function and our policy function and no
model yeah go back with the earlier
slide when the value function is
evaluated nice
yes so why is it not that six that has a
value ten because if you try right at
Essex you get to that seven you were
saying well how do I when do we think of
the rewards happening we'll talk more
about that next time one really there's
many different ways people think of
where the rewards happening some people
think of it as the reward happening for
the current state you're in some people
think of it is it's the reward you're in
and the action you take and some people
some another common definition is our
SAS prime meaning that you don't see
what reward you get until you transition
and this particular definition that I'm
using here we're assuming the rewards
happened as one year in that state all
of them are basically isomorphic but
we'll try to be careful about which one
we're using the most common one we'll
use in that class is si which says that
when you're in a state and you choose a
particular action then you get a reward
and then you transition to your next
date
great question okay so when we think
about reinforcement learning agents and
whether or not they're maintaining these
models and these values and these
policies we had a lot of intersection so
I really like this figure from David
silver where he thinks about sort of RL
algorithms or agents mostly falling into
these three different classes they even
have a model or explicit policy or
explicit value function and then there's
a whole bunch of algorithms that are
served in the intersection of these so
things like actor critic often have an
explicit and what do I mean by explicit
I mean like often they have a way so
that if you give it a stage you could
tell I could tell you what the value is
but I give you a state you could tell me
immediately what the policy is without
additional computation so actor critic
combines value functions and policies
there's a lot of algorithms that are
also in the intersection of all of these
different ones and often in practice
it's just very helpful to maintain many
of these and they have different
strengths and weaknesses for those of
you that are interested in that
theoretical aspects of learning theory
there's some really cool recent work
that explicitly looks at what is the
formal foundational differences between
model-based and model free RL that just
came out of MSR Microsoft research in
New York which indicates that there may
be a fundamental gap between model-based
and model free methods
which on the deep learning side has been
very unclear so feel free to come ask me
about that so what are the challenges
and learning to make good decisions in
this sort of framework um one is this
issue of planning that we talked about a
little bit before which is even once
I've got a model of how the world works
I have to use it to figure out what
decisions I should make in a way that I
think it's gonna allow me to achieve
high reward and in this case if you're
given a model you can do this planning
without any interaction in the real
world so if someone says here is your
transition model and here is your reward
model you can go off and do a bunch of
computations on your computer or buy
paper and decide what the optimal action
is to do and then go back to the real
world and take that action it doesn't
require any additional experience to
compute that but in reinforcement
learning we have this another additional
issue that we might want to think about
not just what I think is the best thing
for me to do given the information I
have so far but what is the way I should
act so that I can get the information I
need in order to make good decisions in
the future so it's like you know you go
to a brand new restaurant and let's say
let's say you move to a new town you go
so there's only one restaurant you go
there to the first day and they have
five different dishes you're gonna be
there for a long time and you want to
optimizing it the best dish and so maybe
the first day you try dish one and the
second day you die try dish two and then
the third day three and then etc so that
you can try everything and then use that
to figure out which one is best so that
over the long term you pick something
that is really delicious so in this case
the agent has to think explicitly about
what decisions it should make so it can
get the information it needs so that in
the future it can make good decisions so
in the case of planning and the fact
that this is already a hard problem and
if you think about something like
solitaire you could already know the
rules of the game it's also true for
things like go or chess or many other
scenarios and you could know if you take
an action what would be the probability
distribution over the next state and you
can use this to compute a potential
score and so using things like tree
search or dynamic programming and we'll
talk a lot more about these I
particularly the dynamic programming
aspect you can use this to decide given
model of the world what is the right
decision to make but solid reinforcement
learning itself is a little bit more
like solitaire without a rulebook we're
here just playing things and you're
observing what is happening you're
trying to get a large reward and you
might use your experience to explicitly
compute a model and then plan in that
model or you might not and you might
directly compute a policy or a value
function now I just want to we emphasize
here this issue of exploration and
exploitation so in the case of the Mars
rover it's only going to learn about how
the world works for the actions it tries
so in state s2 if it tries to go left
you can see what happens there and then
from there it can decide the right next
action now this is obvious but it can
lead to a dilemma because it has to be
able to balance between things that seem
like they might be good based on your
prior experience and things that might
be good in the future but perhaps you
got unlucky before so in exploration
we're often interested in trying things
that we've never tried before or trying
things that so far might have looked bad
but we think in the future might be good
but an exploitation we're trying things
that are expected to be good given the
past experience so here's three examples
of this in the case of movies explore
eat Asian is like watching your favorite
movie
an exploration is watching a new movie
that might be good or might be awful
advertising is showing the ad that Seale
did the most highest click-through rate
so far exploration is showing a
different ad and driving exploitation is
trying the fastest rope given your prior
experience and exploration is driving a
different route
the same policy a great question which
is let's imagine for that example that I
gave that you're only going to be in
town for five days and with the policy
that you would compute in that case if
you're in a finite horizon setting be
the same or different as one where you
know you're gonna live in this for all
of infinite time we'll talk a little bit
more about this next next time but
they're different and in particular the
normally the policy if you only have a
finite horizon is non-stationary which
means that the decision you will make
depends on the time step as well as the
state in the infinite horizon case the
assumption is that the optimal policy in
the Markov setting is stationary which
means that if you're in the same state
whether you're there on time step three
or time step 3000 you will always do the
same thing but in the finite or is in
case that's not as not true
and as a critical example of that so why
do we explore it we explore in order to
learn information that we can use in the
future
so if you're gonna find out horizon
setting it's the last day it's your last
day in Hollywood and you know you're
trying to say what to do
you're not going to explore because
there's no benefit from exploration for
a future because you're not making any
more decisions so in that case you will
always exploit it's always optimal to
exploit so in the finite horizon case
and the decisions you make have to
depend on the value of the information
you gain to change your decisions in
their remaining horizon and it's often
this often comes up in real cases yeah
how much how much more complicated is if
there's a finite horizon but you don't
know where this just I mean it's a thing
I remember from game theory this tends
to be very complicated question is what
about what I would call indefinite
horizon problems where there is a finite
horizon but you don't know what it is
that can get very tricky one way to
model it is as an infinite horizon
problem with termination states so there
are some states which are essentially
sink states once you get there the
process ends this often happens in games
you don't know when the game will end
but it's going to be finite and that
ends so that's one way to put it into
the formalism and
but it is tricky in those cases we tend
to model it as infinite horizon and look
at the probability of reaching different
termination states you miss exploitation
exploration potentially sub problems be
better to kind of exploit tabs you know
we're really good and maybe explore on
sub pass you don't know where it's good
rather than trying like completely
granular you know about how this mix
happens of exploration exploitation and
maybe making sense of cars maybe you
would sort of not try things totally
randomly you might need some evidence
that they might be good it's a great
question there's generally it is better
to intermix exploration and exploitation
in some cases it is optimal to do all
your exploration early or at least
equivalent and then you gain from all of
that information for later but it
depends on the decision process and will
spend a significant chunk of the course
after the midterm thinking about
exploration exploitation it's definitely
a really critical part of reinforcement
learning particularly high stakes
domains what do I mean by high stakes
domains I mean domains that affect
people so whether it's customers or
patients or students that's where the
decisions we make actually affect real
people and so we want to try to learn as
quickly as possible that make good
decisions as quick as we can
any other questions about this if you're
in if you're in a sort of state that you
haven't seen before do you have any
other better option than just like take
a random action to like get out of there
or yeah can you use your previous
experience even though you're not never
been there great if you're in a new
state you've never been in before what
do you do can you do anything better
than random or can you somehow use your
prior experience um one of the really
great things about doing generalization
means that we're gonna use state
features either learned by deep learning
or some other representation to try to
share information so that even though
the nice the state might not be one
you've ever exactly visited before you
can share prior information to try to
inform what might be a good action to do
of course if you share in the wrong
direction you can make the wrong
decision so if you over over generalize
you can over fit to your prior
experience and in fact there's a better
action to do in the news area
okay so one of the things we're going to
be talking about so if in the next few
lectures is this sort of two really
fundamental problems which is evaluation
and control so evaluation is the problem
is saying if someone gives you a policy
if they're like hey this is what you
should do this is what your agent should
do this is how your robot should act in
the world to evaluate how good it is so
we want to be able to off and figure out
you know your manager says oh I think
this is the right way we should show ads
to customers can you tell me how good it
is what's the quick three rate so one
really important question is evaluation
and you know you might not have a model
of the world so you might still have to
go out and gather data to try to
evaluate this policy but you just want
to know how good it is you're not trying
to make a new policy at least not yet
you're just trying to see how good this
current one is and then the control
problem is optimization it's saying
let's try to find a really good policy
this typically involves as a
subcomponent evaluation because often
we're gonna need to know what does best
mean best means a really good policy how
do we know how good the policy is we
need to do evaluation now one of the
really cool aspects of reinforcement
learning is that often we can do this
evaluation off policy which means we can
use data gathered from other policies to
evaluate the counterfactual of what
different policies might do this is
really helpful with because it means we
don't have to try out all policies
exhaustively so um in terms of what
these questions look like if we go back
to our Mars rover example for policy
evaluation it would be if someone says
your policy is this in all of your
states the the action you should take is
try right this is the discount factor I
care about
please compute for me or evaluate for me
what is the value of this policy in the
control case they would say I don't know
what the policy should be I just want
you to give me whatever ever policy has
the highest expected discounted sum of
rewards and there's actually sort of a
key question here is okay expected just
kind of some rewards from what so they
might care about a particular starting
state they might say I want you to
figure out the best policy assuming I'm
starting from s
they might say I want you to compute the
best policy from all starting States or
sort of some average so in terms of the
rest of the course what we're good we
are I was just wondering if it's
possible to learn possible policy and
example if I had some belief what the
reward with you that for some sort of
action state and that turned out to be
wrong I'm gonna have to start over and
training to find an optimal policy or
can I use what I've learned so far in
addition to station great question which
is okay let's say I have a policy to
start with I'm evaluating it and I don't
know what the reward function is and I
don't know what the optimal policy is
and it turns out this current one isn't
very good
do I need to sort of restart or can I
use that prior experience to striven for
them what's the next policy I try or
perhaps a whole suite of different
policies in general you can use the
prior experience in order to inform what
the next policy is that you try our next
suite of policies there's a little bit
of a caveat there which is you need to
have some stochastic D in the actions
you take so if you only take the same
you know one action in a state you can't
really learn about any other actions you
would take so you need to assume some
sort of generalization or some sort of
stochasticity in your policy in order
for that information to be useful to try
to evaluate other policies this is a
really important issue this is the issue
of sort of counterfactual reasoning and
how do we use our old data to figure out
how we should act in the future if the
old policies may not be the optimal ones
so in general we can and we'll talk a
lot about that it's a really important
issue so we're first gonna start off
talking about sort of Markov decision
processes and planning and talking about
how do we sort of do this evaluation and
both when we know how the world works
meaning that we're given a transition
model and reward model and when we're
not then we're also going to talk about
model free policy evaluation and then
model free control we're gonna then
spend some time on deep deep
reinforcement learning and reinforcement
learning in general with function
approximation which is a hugely growing
area right now
I thought about making a plot of how
many papers are going on in this area
right now it's pretty incredible and
then we're gonna talk about policy
search which I think in practice
particularly robotics is one of the most
influential methods right now and then
we're going to spend quite a lot of time
on exploration as well as have a few
advanced topics so just to summarize
what we've done today is talk a little
bit about reinforcement learning how it
differs compared to other aspects with
AI and machine learning we went through
course logistics and started to talk
about sequential decision making under
uncertainty just as a quick note for
next time
we will try to post the lecture slides
two days in advance or by the end of to
you know the evening of two days in
advance so that you can print them out
if you want to in class and I'll see you
guys on what's name